um you have collab projects with some of
the most legendary producers you got an
album with mugs you got a I'm an
alchemist you got a couple of albums of
hairy fraud you got rock Marciano the
collab album coming out yeah for you
what is like
give me kind of like the breakdown on
like the creative process on working
with each one of these guys because I'm
sure it everyone's different yeah
producers creative processes the maybe
you know whether it's recording whatever
what's what's the difference between
everybody everybody
I mean for the most part bro like we all
like friends so you know
um
I like I really like getting in there
with fraud because Fraud's like a good
coach he'll be like nah say it like this
or nah you need to retake that again
um someone recently told me he'd be in
the Hamptons yep that's where we
recorded that second album so we went
out to the Hamptons that [__] was dope
and you know like fraud surf so he'll
like wake up go surfing and then we'll
go you know yeah yeah yeah exactly so um
uh yeah I like everybody's different you
know what I'm saying but um the main
thing is we're all friends so it's like
I like to make music with people that I
know you know I like to have personal
relationships and um
I think that makes the music better you
know what I'm saying when you really
like family like that but um I didn't
say that it felt like the Larry June
album caught a lot of like lists last
year I had I think that's my life yeah
best album last year but do you feel
like that album kind of brought a lot
more eyes to you and your movement and
what you got going on probably so you
know I don't know because like yeah I
mean I'm not one to like I'm I'm a very
private person I don't really like being
in the media too much
um so that one probably you know Larry's
on fire right now there's a great bro
great [__] album thank you I
appreciate that you know that's that's
Sean you know from our group London
drugs and we uh
we put that together but you know me and
Larry is like real life Brothers you
know what I'm saying that's like my best
friend so it was just you know we we'd
been sitting some of those songs are
like six years old crazy put on there
yeah one of the songs the song with Jim
Jones I actually did that verse in 2013
and put it out now you know what I'm
saying but that's why nine years later
yeah Ten Years Later yeah you know and I
just feel like well it came out last oh
yeah it came out last year yeah so I
just feel like you know if it's Timeless
it's Timeless like I don't really feel
like
um you know what I still listen to death
certificate you know I still listen to
dog food you know like it came out
yesterday so
they do the same with my [__] you feel
me I ain't trying to put a um
a year stamp on my [__] like that yeah
for you
I don't feel like I when I I remember
buying like the Giza mugs album
um I remember that it was a great album
um but I feel like mugs doesn't do as
much like full collab projects with
people so I feel like the fact you got
an album with mugs is insane oh yeah
that's a big deal man that's not so
assassin [__] like that shit's a big
deal like where did that relationship
stem from and like well I think mugs
probably got hip to me from Al you know
what I'm saying
um
and just seeing my [__] and you know we
was mutual friends through a lot of
people and one day he was like yeah pull
up to the studio let's make some [__]
and we just started it and you know I
already had in my mind when I go started
something with a producer especially
like a legendary producer like that
I'm trying to get the album done bro
like and you've done a good job of doing
that hey I'm trying to get an album done
you know what I'm saying so
um
yeah uh
that was a great experience you know
that's a legend you know I my first CD I
think I ever bought as a kid
was the Predator you know what I'm
saying so you know he had a lot of
production on there
and you know yeah I came up on Cyprus
and all that [__] so for me it's like
you're in mugs's studio and you're
looking at the plaques and you're like
looking basically looking at an Old
Source magazine and then you like this
is dope you know what I mean so that
[__] was fire how how high is Ice Cube
on your like goats list
that's like the guy you know for sure to
me um as far
is
you know those give me give me your like
top five
your personal favorite I I can't really
do a top five man that [__] is really
hard for me to do man but cube is
definitely in there you know what I'm
saying most definitely
um Cube
Nas is in there too you know
um
I don't know I'm gonna just leave those
two on there those are two good ones
yeah yeah those two for sure because
Illmatic and death certificate those was
like okay yeah
would you consider death certificate his
best album to me yeah I think so to me I
feel like in in I feel like I feel like
it should I feel like it's kind of the
consensus yeah I feel like America's
Most Wanted got the five mics right yeah
yeah because America's Most Wanted is
like but I was a little like just the
style of production for me was like a
little still I was bought I love it I go
back to it now and I really got into it
but when I was like younger I liked like
you know steady mobbing and and [__]
like that I was like oh and then like
you know I'm I'm I still love lethal
injection for sure he's like crazy so I
just had Mac 10 on it I was like dude
I've seen that [__] you know hey I was
like oh [__] yeah yeah that's that's
dope